I've always believed that God is in the
details that it's a drag and you sit
there and you have to try and get it
right but I say I think Twain says the
difference between
the right word and almost the right word
is the difference between you know
lightning and a lightning bug it's just
like that when you get the right wording
when you get it just right
it makes a difference and I think the
work that you and Norm did on update
is proof that well you guys worked
really hard you got fired for it because
unfortunately the the uh the you know
one of the people at the top at NBC was
a good friend of OJ was his closest
friend what's his closest friend uh and
uh you got fired for that and
um but you've always thought that was a
kind of a proud moment for you because a
lot of people reached out when that
happened and identified that that was
the wrong I had so many so I mean it was
really
um I have to say I
I'm not the most uh
sensible person in my personal life you
probably know me well enough Conan and
pick that up but I I'll testify that I
didn't
um
I I had I'd gotten divorced uh um that
year basically so I was sort of um
you know I I maybe I was feeling uh kind
of you know it's kind of ornery and and
like but certainly and also like with a
little less responsibility Norm I know
took it much harder than I did I I sort
of looked at it philosophically and said
you know what it's like
you know the AE Houseman poem to an
athlete dying young you know
um before fame outran the man kind of
thing and and if that's maybe I have
that backwards too but but anyway
um we you know we
we react off and maybe it's that's
better than risking that where you Peak
and then it's down here yeah yeah and
and with we didn't get that we weren't
put in that position of having to you
know to make that decision it was made
for us but um I know that um Norm
the story about that I know you know
this story
um but I think people who are fans of
Norm deserve to know this about him he
they the network went to Norm and said
we want to get rid of Jim Downey uh
um and and we just want you to to know
you're cool with that right he said no
no if you can't fire him if you fire him
I quit and they go that's crazy I mean
you know he's he's not helping you you
know uh the segments to mean or whatever
and um and he said well no I'm I'm not
doing it without him and he never told
me that and I didn't hear that for years
I heard it from some Network Executives
and I I and and part of everything else
if that had been me
that would have been you bet Norm would
have heard you know you want to talk
about it yeah of course I mean come on
Norm didn't I mean he was uh very
stoic old world he came from a different
Center oh yeah I mean I remembered when
he when he died you called me and you
said you were mad at me initially you
said I can't believe you didn't tell me
Conan and I said I didn't know none of
us none of us knew Lori Joe knew and his
mark gervitz his manager knew well his
mother and his son knew yeah and and his
brother so outside of family was like
three people and he didn't and I know
why he didn't I mean I've been told and
it made perfect sense so I believe it
that he um
he just didn't want it to ever be about
anything but being funny he didn't want
to be brave or fighting a good fight or
you know he didn't want to do
heartwarming stuff and
um he just wanted to be but I was a
little hurt that he didn't tell me but I
mean I talked to him
I guess I know you may have talked to
more recently than I'd had but I talked
to him
certainly the summer of 2020. we were
trying we were trying to get him on my
last uh late night show
which is uh two years yeah it was but
not long before he passed and we were
trying really hard to get him to be
because I wanted nothing more than to
him to be one of the last guests and
he was considering it but then wouldn't
do it and then and I think he didn't he
knew that he didn't he also didn't he
knew that his appearance was kind of
changing and he didn't want to yeah but
you know if I I know this is shifting
from one kind of Bravery to another but
he
one of our my proudest moments was a
joke we did and I I think it was a Frank
joke Frank Sebastiano but it was um
there's a certain type of annoying
with exactly what we're talking about
the kiss ass stuff but it was um it was
a joke where we took the world's most
innocuous kind of C-section news story
and it was it was we would clip a real
news story and show it on the monitor so
that the audience knows this is a real
thing we didn't make it up and um we did
that for most of our our things and um
um so the story was like you know
Denver city council approves traffic
light for you know you know Martin
Avenue and so um and so it's we go it
goes enormous like this week the Denver
city council finally on its third
attempt voted funds for a new traffic
light on Martin Avenue then he turns
dramatically to another camera goes
maybe they would have voted the funding
earlier if instead of a traffic light it
was it was for rich white men
we break up a lower third applaud now
but that's the kind of stuff that
there's not really a great place to
laugh in that joke right that's a thing
that like Norm we would we would do our
our run through like we would work on
the jokes a bit during the week but
mainly Friday night and we would that's
when especially I would do a lot of
rewriting and refining and then I'd run
through stuff with norm and then
Saturday we do a run through and then
we're always screaming we were always
kind of late getting in the studio
really late because they were come on
guys we're losing time so we'd come down
to our run through and we'd make a few
kind of changes maybe think of some
things for Norm to add and then um
then we'd have a dress
and then my attitude with Lauren
Michaels the producer the big guy was
always like tell us how long you want
the segment to be we're like because
we're the most easily baloney sliced
segment you know and my attitude and
Norm kind of agreed it's like Norm
wanted a certain he didn't want to feel
that like we you know we had to have we
were entitled a certain amount of the
show but I always argued like anything
if we're cutting lean we're in good
shape you know yeah so I mean sure we'll
always cut the fat that you everyone
should do that but if we also have to
give up something we don't want to give
up it's probably a good indication no no
it's and and so and anyway if it's
something a lot of our stuff can be done
next week yeah you know and so
you know we we used to we would do six
minute updates we I think we did a five
minute they do like 12 minute updates
now you know and they did them before us
and and Norm I will say this normal is
not crazy about features yeah he wasn't
crazy about having other people on the
segment you know always any and
sometimes I had to like get him to be
more involved with him yes but um Seth
Meyers was the best ever at interacting
with I mean he was great at that I wish
Norm had been a little more
playful like the guy always took away
from you and I think about you're in my
head a lot over the years that I've been
writing and all the years that I've been
doing things and you're surprisingly
easy to masturbate too
um
but you're also in my head for another
reason uh no you're in my head because
uh because
there's an ethic that I got from you and
I also got from Robert Smiggle and and I
I try to pick from the best which is
if I can lose it yes trim the fat but
also sometimes cut into the muscle like
and then and uh and lose if you're
losing something for time that you
really love but you love that other
stuff more
uh you're you're in great territory and
this thing is really Gonna Fly yeah and
I think that's great I remembered by the
way the reason I brought all that stuff
up it's because I was just killing time
to remember
Norm was the guy who you know and and
performers because you're you're a
hybrid you know uh performers really
don't want to give up stuff they got a
huge laugh ever Norm would totally throw
out something if he if he came to
suspect it was not the kind of laugh we
wanted and by the way he doesn't that
that doesn't mean like it was dirty or
something if it was like cheap or easy
or whatever and the thing is you could
give Norm a choice like okay this
is absolutely guaranteed to kill it'll
get a mini Standing Ovation but it's
hacky and we both know it this
is guaranteed to die I promise you will
get you know death camp silence but uh
it's brilliant Norm would
unhesitatingly go for the silence on it
never it not you know and I but I would
go yeah I would too but I'm not the guy
out there yeah he is and I always
love that about him he would
never reject something because it's
funny but they're not gonna get they're
gonna laugh you know and I I had fights
with even with people that you and I
both respect who just oh man it killed
it killed you go yeah but come on man